- Deuxième journée d'audience
accablants les uns que les
autres, et i p proviennent
de sa garde rapprochée.apapapape
l'élection, lorsque la chaine
Fox a déclaré Joe Biden
vainqueur en Arizona,
"Rudy Giuliani était en état
d'ébriété", dit Jason Miller,
de Donald Trump.
"Il disait : 'On a gagné!
D'où viennent ces votes?
Il faurerere qu'on a gagné,
quiconque est en désaccord
est faible'."
Et pourtant, ils étaient
nombreux à être en désaccord,
de campagne, Bill Stepien.
aiaiai recommandé au président
de dire à ses partians que
c'était trop tôt pour donneititl
fallait dire qu'on était fier de
notre campagne et qu'il fallait
attendre les prochains jours."
Même sa fille Ivanka Trump
avait des doutes.
ferme, dit-elle. On comptait
encore les votes."
Mais rien à faire, Donald Trump
se déclare vainqueur aux petites
heures
"Les accusations de fraude
affirme l'avocat de renom
Ben Ginsbe
En Pennsylvannie, Donald Trump
clamait que 8 000 morts avaient
voté, des allégations rejettées
par le commissaire électoral
de Philadelphie, qui a subi les
foudres de l'ancien président.et
m'ait ciblé dans ses tweets,
dit-il...
... j'ai reçu des menaécécécécés
non seulement contre moi,
mais contre les membres
de ma famille."
L'ancien ministre de la
Justice, Bill Barr, ne mâche pas
ses modedededededededededededed.
"Il était détaché de la
réalité, dit-ié é é é é é é é é"
Mais ces partisanuuuuuu
et ont décidé d'envahir
le Capitole.
"S'ils pensent qu'ils vonticicu
pouvoir, disait-il, ils se
trompent, ça ne va p
Malgré les preuves accablantes,
Do f f f f f fustige
la commission d'enquête et
la compare à une véritabletttttt
de 12 pages, il maintient qu'il
y a eu fraude électorale.
Les audiences reprennent
mercredi p A A A A A A A A A A ,
Radio-Canada, Washingto